and you and Ken are still close friends
yeah super I mean I you know I love him
dearly he's like Isn't that cool I mean
I have some of those from from working
with people in the past not a lot I
don't I don't have a lot you know you
don't have a lot like you could become
very bonded with a lot of folks on set
and then you know kiss kiss goodbye just
on set together constantly constantly
it's clowning who makes who laugh more
uh I don't know I don't want to be
immodest and say I make Keanu a lot more
because I laughed my ass off the whole
time but at the end of the first week we
looked at each other and we were like
because we hadn't acted together in so
long we just hang out it was like it's
really fun acting together you really
enjoy it it's just really really enjoyed
it yeah we just rip we finish each
other's sentences it's just it's just
it's like being in a band where you like
where you Groove is he sort of like
Uncle Keanu to your kids oh yeah yeah
they all know him yeah he comes and
visits yeah yeah it's always fun to sort
of watch them get old enough to realize
who he is because they never have no
idea otherwise only get to a
certain age they're like oh it's
that guy oh really but then he's been
around like forever too late